the three ball throughout the playoffs
as Jokers falls to the floor he got in a
collision with Schroeder
Murray leans in double clutching got it
[Music]
Murray fires away at three it's good
Jamal Murray struggling all night making
some big buckets here in the fourth
green takes a three shot clock at five
hurry with Davis on it's gonna have to
put it up step back three-pointer that's
good Jamal Murray from way downtown and
Denver goes up four all playing by
himself man gets the switch that he
wants laws Davis to sleep step back
knock down jumper beautiful basketball
by Murray putting the nuggets on his
back
okay
Mario already 8.0 the fourth quarter
finds jokic back to Murray
shot clock whining now puts up a three
Jamal Murray woods again from downtown
nuggets up 12 and Jamal Murray sparking
his team good defense by LeBron caught
gluing down step back knock down three
mean Muslim and see no shooter so
hachimura now has the responsibilities
defending tomorrow
[Applause]
another three-pointer
Murray red
that was terrific transition defense by
Jamal Murray staying in front of LeBron
James
Murray two-point shot that's good
Murray six of seven from the field here
on the four